M
is rape wrong objectively past, present,
future, yes or no?
Given
yes, you shouldn't hesitate here.
It's an object. Why not?
Because Oh, I'm Oh, I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. So So why should So the the base
the base idea of ethics, right? The base
idea of doing ethics is that we
re-evaluate why we believe certain
things and see if they're accurate.
Right? If there is a a proposition that
you believe to be totally true, as I
thought, for instance, um of something
like not being a racist, right? If
somebody asked me, why are you not a
racist? and I immediately say or are you
not a racist and I immediately say yes
of course I'm not a racist right whereas
it pays sometimes even if it seems
ethically obvious to sit back and think
well why do I think that am I sure about
that and the answer can lead you to
other moral
sure what's the answer
so the answer is this right it is
objectively true that to allow people to
rape morally would not be an achievement
of the goal that we all share
that's not the question
that's that's that's the objectivity in
it
yeah but you're answering question
what you want me to do what you want
Wait one second you're answering a
question I didn't ask. I asked a very
clear clear question which everybody I
think understood here, right?
I asked, "Is rape wrong?" OB is that
objectively true? And you're just
beating around the bush.
But the reason why I have to beat around
the bush is because I have to clarify
that remember how I said that a base
principle can be subjective, but you can
have objective derivatives from it. So
in terms of the objective derivative
from our nature, yes, it is objectively
wrong. Yes. Is the answer to your
question.
Based upon the subject,
but you're going to want to turn around
then and say, "But it's based upon a
subjective principle." Yes. Yes, it is
right. But that doesn't mean that I can
say rape is not objectively wrong. I say
that if we agree on this subjective
moral principle, which we do, then we
can make the objective derivative.
Would a rapist agree to that? Of course
they wouldn't.
No, they wouldn't. But again, whether or
not someone agrees with me is irrelevant
to whether it's correct. This is another
Alex. What you're doing is you're
building a house on a sand castle. Yeah.
You are trying to say, look,
if if if you ask me the question, I
would say it's rape is wrong. Yes, it's
wrong objectively. But in your case what
you're basically do you're doing is
you're saying right subjectively some
people may hold this opinion according
to that then since they all
sub all people do hold that opinion and
from that we objectively derive the
rapist
a rapist doesn't of course doesn't hold
that opinion
no no a rapist does value their pleasure
and and the avoidance of
they value their pleasure right so it's
not wrong for them
yeah right okay
because they're maximizing their
pleasure
but look again this is the mistake we're
making I said remember
we're making you're making because
this is this is the man going into town
and saying let's paint the round yellow
the town yellow. This is what the rapist
is doing, right? Just because they're
saying it's all subjective. I want this
to be yellow. I don't want it to be
blue. It's like you are being
this doesn't work. You are wrong. Right?
You are incorrect. Even if it's based on
a subjective based principle, it is
objectively wrong as a derivative to be
the entire argument is based upon the
assumption that everybody likes the
color blue. That's not true. And in
look,
of course, that's not true. But by
analogy by me liking the color, me
liking chocolate or vanilla.
It's as arbitrary for Alex as someone
committing rape or not committing rape.
But it's not as necessary.
Yeah, it's not as necessary.
Do do you see? So for him, it's just as
subjective whether you like chocolate
vanilla or or something else. It's just
as subjective when it comes to rape,
murder, pillaging, all of these things.
And behind all the sophisticated
technical jargon and I'll take that as a
compliment. Essentially,
essentially what it boils down to is the
same thing which Richard Dawkins
admitted to. The idea that rape is wrong
is as arbitrary as the fact that we have
five fingers rather than